[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris sims here to answer all those
questions pro football talk live co-host
let me start with the obvious one what
does it mean to be a kyle
shanahan quarterback chris well
um i think when you talk about a kyle
shanahan quarterback you're talking
about a guy who
can process his information you know at
a really quick
rate knows where to go with the football
off of that decision making and then has
the athleticism
to run the boots and the play action
passes but i think
more than anything it's being able to
take in the
clues of what shanahan can deliver to
you as a quarterback
uh and go listen i i i'm
i'm a mad scientist i've got us in this
formation and i know they're gonna play
one of these two defenses
if you just listen to me and read this
guy
on this play i'll get a and b open you
just gotta read this guy
and take to my coaching and i think
that's what really kyle shanahan looks
for at the quarterback position more
than anything it looks like you doubled
down this morning on mac jones you
tweeted out kyle shanahan gets the most
out of quarterbacks who trust his sis to
make the right reads matt schaab 2009
passing champ kirk cousins in washington
matt ryan 2016 mvp
mac jones is an ideal quarterback for
that
mold more on par with matt ryan
now is this a report or an opinion
no this is an opinion okay though listen
uh kyle's a really good
friend there's no doubt he's not sitting
here telling me his draft plans and what
he thinks he's gonna do at number three
or have you asked him no chris uh
no i have not flat out asked him um
you know i text him things dan like
congrats on the move you know way to go
happy you know hope it all went the way
you want that's where that conversation
goes
now like am i st i'm a good friend
we talk about football a lot and i would
be
shocked if i didn't have a pretty good
feel for
what he likes at the quarterback
position okay you've been tweeting
chris as kyle shanahan commented on your
tweets
no i don't know he is not okay he goes
nor do i think he's even
he's probably oblivious to anything i've
said
or wrote on social media or anything
like that
but you know this is you know 20 years
of me knowing a guy
a guy that yes i talk a lot of football
with
all of the time right uh we talk about
quarterbacks a lot
off season regular season whatever it
may be and
i would just have a hard time thinking
it's not mac
jones at number three i really would one
because of what shanahan likes
and then two you know yeah i'm taking it
into you know you know i think zach
wilson is the number one quarterback in
the draft but i still think trevor
lawrence is going to go to jacksonville
i think the jets will go to zack wilson
now totally 100
confirmed after that workout on friday
and then when i look at it and go all
right now shanahan the 49ers you're at
three
that to me is mac jones to make that
move we know it's a quarterback
but i just think fields and lance have
work in front of them
there's some polish there's some you
know some things they need to work
on and you don't trade up nine spots
to get a quarterback that has things to
work on that's why i think it's mac
jones
okay so what's jimmy g's future
i would think i mean they got two
options they could
keep him right and then go where i will
wait for mac jones to
you know come along and give him a year
on the bench but i think
as i said to mike floria today that's
risky the 49ers you see them
they got a good team they almost they
were in the playoff hunt last year with
the the most
injuries in the history of the nfl so
you go with jimmy garoppolo and what go
you know 12 and four or something like
that what does that do to your number
three pick so i would think ultimately
that jimmy g is put on the trade block
and that mac jones would be the starter
or whoever they pick at number three
uh going into the 2021 season 12 and
five
maybe because they're 17. you're right i
got to get you 9 2
2. i used to say seven and nine eight
and eight if all goes well nine and
seven i gotta change all of that chris
oh man okay what do the jets do
at what point do they lose their
leverage here in trying to get something
for sam darnold if they're taking zach
wilson
right i i heard you that i heard you say
that before it came out that's that's a
good question
i mean you don't hurt your leverage as
long as there's more than one team that
can get involved in the conversation as
far as trading right
right now i can look at two teams to go
i think there's legitimate and maybe
there's three teams because we don't
know i don't think the russell wilson
staying in seattle is a hundred percent
yet i think we should watch these final
five weeks
but i look at carolina and the denver
broncos
as two places where i still think are
looking for a quarterback
i do carolina i mean hey we know they've
given us all the signals that
they're trying to find an upgrade from
teddy bridgewater you know the denver
broncos i'd be hard-pressed
with vic fangio his butt probably on the
line you're just gonna roll out the red
carpet and go i'm going down with drew
locke
i wouldn't i'd at least have somebody
there to compete or
okay he didn't play well the first three
weeks here's another guy
so that would be the thing i would look
at right now because yes i do think the
jets are going to go zach wilson
and uh hopefully they can have a market
for sam darnold and get what they
what they see is worth for him so if we
have quarterbacks going one two three
why not one two three four with atlanta
a lot of people think that you know
there's a lot of people in the nfl that
think atlanta's hot on trey lance
and might take him number four i i mean
again i wouldn't do that i would not
you know i i've discussed with you a
little i think with with trey lance
there is some elite traits there's no
doubt
i mean his speed and his arm strength
are wow
but there's a lot of other things that i
question and that to me doesn't scream
the number four pick
but i think if you talk to a lot of
people in the know around the nfl they
think atlanta's hot on trey lance and
you know again i'm never going to be a
mad at a team if they think
that's their guy and they're sold on
that to me i would just go what
what are you sold on quite yet there he
didn't play last year
he didn't throw a lot the year before
and there's some things in the throwing
that i would say i just don't feel 100
comfortable with right now too and you
still think zach wilson
is going to be a better pro than trevor
lawrence
i do yeah i mean i'm you know
we talk about the the pro day right on
friday i mean it was wowing
the degree of difficulty of those throws
and then the way in which he passed the
test
was wowing not to say other quarterbacks
can't do that
i get that you know but i i but
but here's the thing this is where
people are missing this they're going
you know i hear somebody well it's it's
a workout who cares it's
it's no big deal well first thing i
would say is
when the film matches the workout then
you go oh
okay wait there's something there i see
all these throws on film
and now he does it in a workout and does
it easily
second of all there's maybe more
pressure to doing it in that environment
than there is a game
a game you're reacting you're doing what
you have to do
at a workout you're basically putting
yourself out there
you know and you miss four or five of
those throws and all of a sudden you go
whoa
you know i'm trying to be cool and do
these high-level throws and here i have
i've thrown five or six incompletions
and that can you know snowball out of
control but this guy's so good they just
went nah
it ain't gonna happen it doesn't matter
if it was so easy
why doesn't everybody do this at their
pro day right that's what i want to say
so there was great confidence that even
on his worst day
they felt like he could still pass it
with flying colors
and i think that's what maybe people are
missing not to say it translates to
definite awesomeness
i know you got to play the game on the
field but that still was an awesome
workout
talking to chris sims pro football time
talk live co-host with mike florio yeah
but i'll go back to zach wilson
you know that's the impact of patrick
mahomes that workout
was to say this is the new quarterback
mahal those were this is a new phrase
mahomesean throws
that that's what zach wilson did he gave
you mahomezian
throws i agree it's the mahomes effect
it's the mahomes the rogers
you know you know i feel like my homes
affected josh allen
you know and now you're gonna see yeah
more and more of these quarterbacks
trying to be this type of football
player
you know one because the game's wide
open right now in a lot of ways
the quarterbacks are as talented as
we've ever seen
and what it really shows and like we see
with mahomes on the field and i think
what zack wilson showing you is going
hey yeah i can hit the open curl in the
open out route
but look when it's third and 14 and
we're not playing our best look what
else i can do oh the pass protection's
not good or nobody's open
look i could still get it done guys even
when things aren't perfect
and i think you're totally right that is
the mahomesian effect and i would think
as the years go we're going to see more
and more of these type of workouts and
quarterbacks come up the ranks
i also wonder about wide receivers here
with devonta smith jamar chase
that it feels like jamar i was told from
two months ago a scout said he liked
jamar chase over devonta smith
miami is now out of that position to
take devonta smith at number three
doesn't mean they still can't
but handicap those two if you're the
bengals do you reunite jamar chase with
joe burrow
and if you're miami are you still trying
to reunite devonta smith with tuatanga
by law
i mean i'm thinking about it either way
and you know again like
you talked about i think miami they did
a great job of kind of putting
themselves in a spot where you basically
go oh
they should get at least one of those
two guys no matter what
at number six or kyle pitts out of
florida or kyle pitts out of florida
right which is not gonna be bad either
yeah you really have to make that pick
going or make that trade going wait
you know out of there's three guys we
like that we'll be happy with that are
right there
you know devonte smith and jamar chase i
went into the process dan thinking jamar
chase was gonna be the clear number one
when i watched the film i went whoa like
that was
that was you know you know i mean like
by a hair
i would take jamar chase over demonte
smith it's like 1a and 1b
they're both really talented football
players i do wonder with the bangles at
five
you know they have decent receivers no
doubt they got higgins at the top of the
first round last year
you know pass protection is a thing for
them too would they go online there i
don't know it'd be interesting
because they could add another weapon to
the arsenal and be real scary that way
but i do think at least it assures that
the dolphins get a weapon there and
i don't think you can go wrong you know
dan everybody talk about devante smith
is he big enough and all that i'd be
concerned if the film
showed me something like that but man
his strength his route running
his feet and then his just pure speed
are so special that i don't i don't see
it being an issue
do you care about the size of a wide
receiver as a quarterback
i mean like
throwing to a really small receiver down
the field
can be one thing that maybe you care
about right
like the john browns of the world
sometimes throwing them a ball downfield
when a guy's covered
that's not the most comfortable thing in
the world but after that
no you don't really think about it a
whole lot now as you get to know these
guys you get to know what their
radius is and where their window is
right to where now you go oh wait i'm
throwing to that guy
and that guy can catch a ball if i throw
it five feet behind him still
so let me be safe and put it there and
maybe he gets it or no one gets it that
goes through your
your your uh process when you're
throwing as a quarterback in the pocket
dan
would you rather have a wide receiver in
the top 10 or
a tight end would you rather have jamar
chase or kyle pitts or devante smith
i would rather have the the receivers i
would yeah i mean i like pits they're
great weapons everything they do
i just i mean guys like devonta smith
and jamar chase are game changers
they're home run hitters oh here's a
reverse
70 yards here's a slant 70 yards oh just
run by that guy with pure speed
70 yards and then you know 50 50 balls
with those type of guys are really like
70 30 type balls so that's where
i favor those guys by the way mac jones
was referred to as
subtly athletic today not deceptively
but but now he's subtly i think he's
athletic for the position i
i don't know what like is the context
rg3
or is it like i
can't see measurables that are similar
to andrew luck and i thought andrew luck
was athletic
i i agree it's being way too
over talked about hyped up of a thing
there's no doubt about it yeah no he's
not mahomes or josh allen
or rg3 that was mahomes's 40-yard dash
i you know what i don't even know i
would guess it was four sevens
low four seven so i'm gonna guess yeah i
mean was he
deceptively athletic no you know and
again i just
i'll look it into it and go into a two
to go wait you know oh it's one thing to
say
wait hold on chris what was mahomes is
40 uh
4 8 40. oh man
damn i i wouldn't take him i think i
might have to pass on him
yeah yeah the hell with that the hell
with it mitchell trubisky had a faster
40-yard dash
right and there's nothing about that
says mitchell trubisky is better in the
pocket or
avoiding people or doing anything like
that again it's like devonte smith dan
it's like if the film showed me that
there was
issues there i would go oh yeah but
there's too many great plays of movement
in the pocket
avoiding people then making great throws
or just getting outside the pocket to
buy enough time to throw a great ball
on the run he's every bit as athletic or
more athletic than matt
ryan coming out and other quarterbacks
like that that's who he's going to be
it's not going to be mahomes or aaron
rodgers or anything like that
good to talk to you chris as always uh
we'll keep an eye
we love your predictions and uh thanks
man you know but
hey keep fritzy off the cookies and
cream man i mean he can't be doing that
he can't i you know i've seen his belly
he can't do that
no no it's a healthy it's a health bar
this is
i'm okay with this yeah okay this is
okay
yeah he used to eat actual cookies and
cream chris
this is a protein bar it's when i ate
three of the protein bars in one sitting
that's what the problem is
thank you well yeah come on contain
yourself one's enough fritzy come on
i'll do better thanks man
thank you chris that's chris sims from
pro football talk live
every morning with mike florio